mes amis bonjour à toutes et à tous ça
fait plusieurs années que je viens au
touquet même quand ce n'était qu' un
petit campus régional que nous avons
réussi à porter en campus nationale
grâce à la fougue des hommes qui sont
ici et ce qu'ils étaient avant et depuis
deux trois ans je vous fait passer ce
message qui maintenant on doit raisonner
de manière douloureuse à vos oreilles
la france n'est plus face à
l'immobilisme d'une politique la france
est en coma artificiel
on est dans une situation dramatique
avec un président qui après avoir été
inexistant n'est plus à la hauteur
et comme dirait mon ami jean-pierre
raffarin c'est un problème de leadership
je laissais l'adage quand je regarde les
quand je me regarde dans le miroir je
m'inquiète quand je regarde les autres
je me compare quand hollande se regarde
dans un miroir j'espère qu'ils
s'inquiètent mais quand il se compare à
merkel se pense qu'il doit se désole
parce que nous avons honte de ce
président là qui dans des circonstances
extrêmement difficiles et mon ami
geoffroy didier va vous en parler un peu
plus que moi sur la question de
l'immigration qui est une de ces
spécialités dans des circonstances très
difficiles devraient tirer la france
vers l'eau trouver la réponse adaptée
prendre les initiatives être le fer de
lance de l'europe n'arrête pas de faire
des têtes à queue des virages à 180
degrés à force de se retourner sans
arrêt sur lui même il va se retrouver
forcément dos à dos avec ce qui lui
pendait qu'est ce que vous voulez on est
dans une situation qui nécessite à un
moment de tracer une voie de donner à un
horizon
à notre population qui ne sait plus vers
qui se tourner et ce qu'elle peut croire
et c'est comme ça qu'on dérive vers les
extrêmes tout le monde le sait vous avez
entendu nicolas sarkozy je l'espère tout
au moins à la télévision
quelle différence quel charisme
quelle capacité à exprimer en même temps
ce qu'est l'âme de la france son honneur
accueillir des gens des réfugiés
politiques qui fuient la mort et la
barbarie mais en même temps affiché la
fermeté nécessaire pour dire on peut
plus continuer dans cette politique
qu'ils dévient sans arrêt nicolas qu'on
avait accusé de parler des frontières on
comprend bien aujourd'hui
pourquoi il avait parlé des frontières
on comprend bien aujourd'hui pourquoi il
avait dit qu'il fallait refonder
complètement schengen et moi qui était
ministre de plusieurs ministères sociaux
sous jacques chirac et sous nicolas
sarkozy je peux vous dire que nous ne
pouvons plus accepter dans le futur de
garantir des prestations sociales à des
personnes qui sont des clandestins qui
sont des fraudeurs et qu'il faudra
revoir complètement complètement le
modèle d'immigration et le modèle social
de la france ce qui ne veut pas dire que
quand nous sommes confrontés à cette
question de populations qui fuient
provisoirement leur pays
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut s'occuper
aussi des cause de l'hémorragie en syrie
en irak nous n'ayons pas du coeur et la
capacité de les accueillir à quelques
conditions toutefois
quand j'étais ministre de la lutte
contre la pauvreté en 2004 ont dépensé à
peu près un milliard d'euros pour
l'hébergement d'urgence des migrants je
suis devenu quelques années plus tard
ministre toujours de la lutte contre la
pauvreté en charge des solidarités
actives ont dépensé un milliard deux
cents millions d'euros on en dépense
mois cette année
et pendant ce temps là madame merkel
elle met 6 milliards d'euros pour
accueillir vingt mille réfugiés
supplémentaires
l'état n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'il doit faire
le deuxième message que devrait vous
apporter les plus régionale c'est normal
c'est le président
deux des républicains du nord et vous
savez bien que nous sommes engagés dans
un combat important et difficile pour
les régionales qui n'est pas qu'un
combat régional qui est un combat
national
tout le monde comprend bien que si
madame le pen gagne la région nord pas
de calais c'est pas la même donne aux
présidentielles que si elle la gagne pas
tout le monde a bien compris aussi que
xavier bertrand notre leader a réussi à
insuffler cette dynamique cette capacité
d'unité a bien sûr il faut faire quelque
part de temps en temps de la place à nos
partenaires et il faut essayer de tout
traité mais enfin quelle différence je
lisais la voix du nord ce matin
rendez vous compte la gauche plurielle
qui est devenu lagos plus rien d'un côté
d'un côté les khmers verts faut pas
parler comme ça paraît les verts
intégristes si vous voulez avec la
motion de madame rousseau qui recueille
dans la grande région nord pas de calais
picardie de six millions d'habitants 95
oui c'est moi que dans ma section de
lambersart 28 mille habitants et donc
qui veut afficher sa ligne autonomistes
de l'autre côté madame barbara pom pom
plie pas excusez moi les hollies donc
temps en temps j'ai pensé à marilyn
monroe qui recueille 25 voix et donc on
se demande existentiellement ci va y
avoir une liste plusieurs listes à
gauche
de l'autre côté chez les rouges les
rouges vifs du parti communiste qui
veulent l'autonomie et les rouges roses
du front de gauche qui veulent l'union
mais envisage plutôt d'aller avec les
verts intégristes plutôt qu'avec d'aller
avec les roses quand même à la fin tout
le monde et maro c'est un peu compliqué
coire et donc
moi je vous dis tranquillement nous
sommes face à un choix simple pour les
régionales d'un côté notre leader xavier
bertrand une dynamique à slogan clair la
région travail parce que c'est le sujet
majeur pour nous aujourd'hui l'emploi et
le travail qui met toutes ses forces et
nous allons mettre toutes nos forces et
mon ami edouard courtial qui va parler
dans un instant le président du
département de l'oise vous le dira avec
la même vigueur dans tous nos
départements pour gagner cette campagne
et expliquer notre projet expliqué que
le nord pas de calais picardie ça peut
pas être la grèce on peut pas accepter
sans rien dire que madame le pen qui
elle c'est un homme c'est autre chose
elle c'est la fille qui est la fille
naturelle mais qui n'est plus la fille
spirituelle d'ailleurs n'a jamais été
spirituel mena mme le pen pour dire mal
et donc d'un côté nous avons cette
force-là et de l'autre côté une force de
régression de populisme qui quelque part
nous fera perdre tout notre activité
économique est quelque part nous fera
tourner le dos à l'europe
nous devons nous mobiliser clairement
pour cette campagne et nous nous devons
nous dire en même temps que ce faisant
nous contribuons à la victoire que nous
attendons tous pour les présidentielles
les socialistes j'avais vu j'ai pas trop
critiquer les socialistes c'est quand
même il faut il faut leur pardonner quoi
ils ont beaucoup de patience et
socialiste il y en a encore
certains qui continue à attendre ce qui
n'arrivera jamais faut quand même avoir
la pitié pour eux c'est pas facile dans
le nord il avait dix mille militants ils
sont passés à 1,5010 ce matin donc ils
vous expliquent déjà que ça va pas bien
qu'ils vont pas y arriver nous
avec mon ami bernard gérard et dans le
pas-de-calais daniel fasquelle avec le
philippe rappeneau et dans les
départements continuent également nous
sommes en pleine dynamique d'adhésion et
vous venez vers nous et vous avez raison
pas pour notre bonne tête et pour nous
faire plaisir parce que vous savez qu'il
y a un enjeu majeur pour les régionales
et que derrière cet enjeu majeur joue un
rôle capital pour les présidentielles et
que nous attendons l'alternance j'en
terminerai sur mon troisième message
parce qu'il faut pas que ce soit trop
long pour vous dire
ne parlons pas pour l'instant des
primaires n'allons pas dans le jeu des
autres qui se divise
on a la chance d'avoir des leaders et
des hommes d'état et des femmes d'état
n'a qu'à nathalie kosciusko morizet avec
nous cet après midi et hal a du mérite
dans ce qu'elle fait et je la salue
parce que à la carne à la carne aussi
une certaine idée de la jeunesse que n'a
pas incarné olemps nous avons dans nos
rangs des hommes et des femmes d'état
qui quelque part le moment du front les
choses en toute loyauté et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des images d'unité tout le
temps tout le temps et que nicolas
sarkozy quand il a pris la présidence de
notre mouvement il a eu cette obsession
de l'unité et qu'il continuera mais il
faudra bien se dire le moment venu qu'en
2017 dentier de la situation de coma
artificiel qui est celle de la france ce
qui nous faudra c'est pas un analgésique
pour calmer la douleur c'est quand même
le traitement nécessaire pour traiter
les causes de la maladie
épouvantable que traverse la france et
là il vous faudra du charisme de
l'énergie du coeur et du souffle ce sera
le moment venu en attendant je coeurs je
compte sur votre coeur
votre souffle et votre énergie pour les
régionales de 2015 merci à tous